that's what I think the Iraq war has
failed miserably is that democracy is
not just about elections is about
institutions it's about civil liberties
is about all of these good education
good infrastructure that was not I mean
and that was not built even though some
may argue that was the intention of the
war but as you dig in more and you see
the corruption between the contractors
and other contractors and suddenly just
the money disappears for some reason
which was all meant for kind of
rebuilding institutions I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report quick note
everybody we've changed up our
publishing schedule so going forward
clips are going up throughout the week
and our full interviews will be right
here on YouTube on Sundays and of course
click that subscribe button and turn on
notifications blah blah blah and more
portly joining me today is the founder
of ideas Beyond Borders a brand new
American citizen Faisal al Muhtar
welcome back to the Rubin report hello
there how are you good I find thank you
for asking I dropped the Saeed there I
said Faisal al Muhtar do you go by
Faisal Saeed all Muhtar I go yes Allah
moot are actually not sure I go with
faisal site for a reason I mean Society
is my dad's name yeah and the reason I
kept it is because I have a very strong
relationship with my dad and the reason
why he raised me to be the person that I
am I mean some people keep the dad's
name away but I kept my dad's name and
actually in my first name so I can
maintain my relationship with him
alright then I feel I should look at you
and do that intro again welcome to the
show Faisal Saeed Al Butare thanks safe
thank you I am very excited to have you
here my friend because as of right now
you are now a five-time Rubin report
guest I believe that puts you in the
Jordan Peterson Ben Shapiro category
well I'm you oh that's a recent
immigrant to the United States I think
I've made it that's it I'm out of this
country actually when I was just I was
just notice is that you really notice
all my developments since I came to the
States you actually like it if people if
your audience watch the previous
episodes to now they will see like
pretty much my I think you interviewed
me one year after my get my green card
mm-hmm and so this was around
2014 I think 2014-2015 no is 2015 yeah
fall of 2015
yeah that's was one year after I get my
green card which is in 2014 I landed in
Los Angeles in 2013 and then yeah and
then Here I am
yeah that was like it's kind of
mind-boggling yeah well we'll have a
playlist of just the interviews that
I've done with you and it is an
interesting evolution and we're going to
talk with you and all that but it's
funny because when you were on the way
this morning and I was thinking about
what I wanted to talk about and ideas
Beyond Borders and everything else that
you're doing you feel to me like an old
friend but it's funny because we only
know each other for four or five years
and a lot of what we know about each
other is public old a lot you know yeah
but it shows you how fast things you're
changing because it does feel this feels
like an old friendship to me I mean
which is weird cuz I'm gonna feel like
we've known each other for 30 years I
mean five years this is a one fifth of
my age but yeah I've known you have
known you since yeah since I came to the
United States almost yeah yeah alright
so and and I hope the friendship
continues that's well let's just see
let's see how about tonight yeah okay so
first off you are a brand-new American
citizen and I want to talk about table
so you got the leather jackets about you
are loved in America but for people who
don't know who you yeah because
obviously the show has grown a lot since
way back when I know yeah talk a little
bit about your story in Iraq growing up
in Iraq and the war and everything yeah
let's do a quick recap on that well I
mean I was born in Babylon but below in
Iraq and then my dad year that was 1991
okay so right after the first Gulf War
and under the sanctions you're a young
kid well when you hear the story or more
mature than average but and so I I was
born in 91 and then my parents moved to
Baghdad as I was seven or eight years
old and my dad's an orthopedic surgeon
my mom is a lawyer so I come from but my
dad stayed in the UK and came back to
the country to fix Iraq but then Saddam
Hussein went to the Gulf War and then
that country went downhill
so you born during the Gulf War no I
yeah the Gulf War was was 19 1990 and
then and then so I and then after
the data from the oxide we declared the
one the war has one correct and called
the mother of all battles and so that
happened and then as I was going up I
grew up under Saddam Hussein and I mean
one of the main attic doors that I was
actually relevant who are saying is that
I didn't know that Iraq invaded Kuwait
the way that was manufactured by both
the state and then there was a mosque
next to our house called the mother of
all battles with the manera is designed
as a ballistic missile and naked 47 Wow
so Saddam Hussein start building mosques
all over the country with missiles or
namond at the top yes and so that was
like undeclared Iraq to be kind of an
Islamic state which brings us to the
future but he's the one who put god is
great on the flag so the environment I
was growing up in even though the
misconception generally is like Saddam
used to be secular and all of that I
grew up in era called the faith campaign
in which Saddam actually demos and moved
Iraq to become moral religious states so
before you were born though so when your
parents were younger yeah it was more of
a secular or it Saddam was more saying
yes and then after the war relatively
and it was more Arab nationalist so Arab
nationalism was kind of the face that
first said that moved in it was in a war
with Iran and we had to differentiate
ourselves as the Arabs versus the
Persians and Iranians all of that
essentially the battles caused parties
here which is also relevant to the
battle so anyway so 2003 happened so
that's where the Iraq war so the area
that I used to live in was an area in
which many of Saddam generals used to
live in so as the war happened and Iraqi
military was defeated obviously many of
these generals start leaving the
district and the houses became all empty
so from suddenly follow residential area
with a lot of people so lives like many
of the houses were on the highway
totally all empty meaning they were
going to fight or they were fleeing no
they were fleeing the country many of
them either went to Jordan or some other
Arab state some of them went different
provinces we don't know honestly but but
I know that they left and so after these
houses became empty and then now
suddenly chaos start erupting in the
country these houses are being taken
over by al-qaeda
so from normal families and now
militias walking the streets so the use
of what what was that really like so now
you're in your Yahoo do you wanna live
and suddenly okay now there's abandoned
house yeah I don't know where these
people when they got out of the Army and
now al Qaeda shows up I mean what is
that actually like so so what is like is
what your what I think many people have
seen in videos of when these militias
take over the usual the usual day was
there is an IEDs and IEDs an explosive
device that they put in the street so
when there's a US Humvee comes in or
eventually Iraqi army starts coming up
blow up and then kill some soldiers and
then there's a fight back and all of
that so that's cuz this is the usual day
that's that's what people do on the
weekend and if I mean from my end I mean
I've seen I mean I've seen it all from
people firing rockets or us thanks to
beheadings
to dead people on the street so that was
my my that's why that's was my high
school era so the more times you're
seeing that at lately like 14 years old
50s something like that like what does
that do to a 14 year olds mind like what
did you think was happening I will talk
about that actually after moving to a
safer area and kind of getting that
actually I said now is that I just a
year ago I was just sitting in my patio
of my friends patio and it just came in
to me is like wow I've been safe for a
while like this is this normal life
looks cool this kind of because the
usual day is I mean I mean my mom was
obviously tortured as well as that she
never know whether her kid is gonna come
back to to house so so yeah it's like
I've had this realization actually kind
of recently is like I've this this
normal life which is like not to worry
about bum bangs and and and and suicide
attacks and all of that at the time was
my normal that was actually and after a
while somebody get desensitized honestly
I mean after you constantly start seeing
it and there are whole environment is
like that it's like yeah you talk to a
friend is like oh just my brother get
killed okay you wanna grab lunch
seriously this is actually the the mood
of the day and so so that was you know
way these were like the first two years
were the good years so even though there
were IEDs and and some suicide bombers
there were the good days and then there
was a major day happened in Iraq in
which al-qaeda blew up one of the
largest Shia mosques in the country
it's called Minar scary which is an area
in northern Baghdad and as a result now
the Shia militias start popping up and
my neighborhood luckily was just in the
middle between these two so they start
firing rockets at each other so and that
rocket can mouth most of these people
are inexperienced of the rocket can hit
a school that can hurt the house it can
so again the usual day is Oh somebody's
house was blown up quickly explain
around with the Sunni Shia split here
because I think somebody might hear oh i
okay to blew up a sunni ma ma yeah and
not understand why that would they would
do that well I mean the history is long
but in at least in the modern context as
Iraq Saddam Hussein used to be Sunni
which is relevant in this conversation
so after so many of the generals and the
military used to be from the Sunni at
least the leadership were most of them
are Sunnis so that created and they are
the minority in Iraq they're they
represent and obviously some of them
were dissident as Saddam Hussein but but
generally speaking the perception is
that Sunnis were the ones controlling
after that the then the Iraq's are
getting divided into militia so the
Iraqi civil identity start being
destroyed so most people start went back
to their religion and their sect mainly
their sect and the Shia militias I mean
the main funder of that I mean funding
is a little much very relevant here
funding of the Shia militias come from
Iran and the funding from the Sunni
militias come from Qatar and Saudi
Arabia and the Gulf states and they have
a different in a way it's a power
struggle who actually controls the
country and what vision they have to the
concept within the Sunni then the Sunni
militias is the concept that the
Caliphate which is that the ISIS is Al
Qaeda's and within the Shias is their
Tollywood ITA which is the that the Shia
have a version which is kind of similar
to Christianity in a way
there was a 12th Imam who was hidden and
how many and how many now in Iran it's
kind of the representative of that human
on earth until he comes back so in a way
they're both theocratic authoritarian
but they have a different vision of what
theocratic authoritarianism looks like
in practice and and where the funding
goes which I want to talk a little bit
more later related to Qatar is really
yeah yeah and the funding so I've
written a article when I was in Iraq and
later on that I translated which is that
it's easier to start a terrorist group
in the Middle East and to start a
liberal one and many of the reasons is
that I mean I've seen funding going like
in front of me like I've been to a
restaurant and a guy came in with a bag
of cash giving it to somebody and he's
like oh go fight with the Mujahideen and
all of that so so see like they were
towards some of that funding was really
public it was not really like hidden say
yeah so so that happened and then
suddenly Iraq erupted to a much more
sectarian civil war at the beginning it
was we still lose maybe 5,000 a month or
now it became recent months to 25,000 or
30,000 and that's where I lost my
brother and my my cousin that was the
big peak of 2007 that was when when
things were erupting and my crazy me at
the time were like oh why don't
everybody get along attitude and I was
with my friends and so who were more on
the liberal liberal side so you you were
like starting atheist groups at that
time not Isis but but mostly like
secular anti anti anti theocracy I mean
we had like some people who are
religious with us who were also
antagonistic or so a different version
of Islam or necessarily believe in it
that much so yes it was kind of more
inclusive than than just non-believers
what was that like oh to be starting a
group or just be around people that
we're doing something that's pretty
subversive yeah I mean first it started
online first is is that's not how we
find ourselves online when when Saddam
was in power we didn't have we hardly
all had to state television and
barrilito internet just called internet
which is only local Internet and then
when the internet shows up which is
which is after the
war then everything was opened up so the
rock rock at the time the internet was
as open as this year in the United
States you can access every website and
every thing and at the time there were
there was a website called blogspot
which is kind of part of Google
Googlebot and then through other elect
forums and and that's what I started and
then after a while like okay where do
you live or even Baghdad are you here
and then mostly many times people don't
reveal their identity for obvious
reasons and but I was able to with also
from some of my friends they were able
to formulate groups in which we meet up
and discuss things unfortunately after a
while that it start becoming a target so
we went back to hiding and I after the
loss of my brother and my cousin and and
getting multiple death threats I left at
a country so I left I left Iraq in 2009
I left the to Lebanon so that's the
second phase of my life in which post
Iraq which I left I remember the day I
left Iraq it was 99 to 4 2009 September
9 2009 and so Iraq at the time was still
in its war zone there was not not
nothing much happening and I know I've
asked you this before but can you talk a
little bit how how'd you get over the
border and all so so I didn't have a
quarrel with Iraqi government so I
should I left through the usual airport
they rocky used to be called Saddam
International Airport it became
eventually Baghdad International Airport
so so I was okay to leave the country
from this state because the state didn't
have any if that the state was sectarian
but I mean I'm the last of their worries
I wasn't really targets but my
neighborhood might the whole part of
West Baghdad where I come from there
were several parts for example called
special olive line which means Afghan
Street so these are all Afghans came
from Afghanistan who came and fought in
Iraq against against either you a small
tree or the ROC government there were
like Chechnya ins and there were a lot
of people from all these days so we
became like the Time Square of terrorism
so whatever you think of whatever nation
that had foreign fighters they all came
and some of them actually came before
the war I mean when the war went when
the war ended I remember I saw my first
American which was an abrams tan
come and get in front of my house and
that was in April 2003 and how did you
feel it because this is where you have
an interesting perspective yeah Oricon
foreign policy relative to all this so
you see the tank going by what do you
think it's I mean first is definitely
scary but at the same time it was a
feeling of relief I mean the life of the
last year's of Saddam Hussein where
because he knew at the time he was going
to lose power of some sort so he was
more authoritarian than usual and the
sanctions were hitting stronger on Iraq
more and more to the way that Iraqi
economy was destroyed almost destroyed
so it was kind of a relief I mean what
is there to lose really kind of attitude
is that well maybe these guys are gonna
make it better and my parents even
though did not publicly were opposed to
Saddam Hussein but they were not found
they were not fans I mean considered
that both of them were educated and they
wanted they had a lot of skills that
they can contribute to make the country
a better place and he kept going from a
war to a war destroying the Iraqi
economy / destroying Iraq in general
killing tons of people hundreds of
thousands of people not worth it when
the sanctions were happening before the
war were there people that basically
were like if he would just change his
tune if he would stop doing certain
things then America would ease up on the
side where the international community
ease up on the sanctions and things
would actually get better like like he
sort of made his bed yeah and it depends
who you ask I mean if you ask the Kurds
they will tell you like he gassed us
multiple times and now there's no
there's no negotiation here if you ask
some people who are having relatively
safe for life and also we didn't know
what what the alternative was I mean now
many people say oh we wish Saddam is
back or sub damaged to be safe but the
time many people didn't know that Iraq
would would erupt in such chaos so so so
everything happens in comparison is that
I if it was better back then it was
better more wars before so yeah it
depends who you ask I mean there's there
are people if you go to southern part of
Iraq which there was kind of a semi Arab
Spring happened in 1981 after the first
Gulf War the usual houses you see
pictures of dead child dead son
and I think these guys have a different
perspective who everyone said them to
stay or not
all right and if he stayed and he was
old most likely his son would have been
the president which is a day Saddam
Hussein who was far more I mean if you
things are done with evil this guy is
even on steroids so yeah it's it's it's
a I mean I I struggle with these
questions I might not really have the
best answer to them but I think is that
it all depends what you value if what
you value for example what I value is
for some freedom of information yes Iraq
is doing much better in terms of
information they are much more
accessibility to information so if you
want to democratize or move the society
to become more accepting of
enlightenment values or or any values
that you'd like to promote Iraq is more
suitable for it now than it used to 2003
the same way Syria I mean Sierra now is
under Assad it's equivalent to what it
used to be in terms of authoritarianism
on information since it all depends what
you value if you value safety Saddam
Hussein some were much safer but how did
he kept it safe by putting people in the
gulag equivalent of a gulag I mean that
I mean that's its authoritarian safety
it's not like safety as and everybody
getting along but it's more like if you
speak your mind you gonna get killed
so of course you getting safety safe so
it's but you get a lot of pushback when
you say that sort of thing right when
you say that that Iraq now even though
Iraq is obviously still a mess and there
was that brief moment and I do want to
focus on a little bit that brief moment
where there were free and fair election
you know basically free and sounds and
the whole world saw it but then the US
under Obama just pulled out just like
that and then things got much worse but
at that little moment when there were
the elections do you think more people
were thinking like you just said cuz I
see you say this sort of thing right now
that America has sort of freed Iraq in a
lot of ways and then I see the amount of
hate that you get from yeah usually
unfortunately from the lefties I mean
again is this so I mean I'm as I grow
older cousin quote is that I think is
that even these fair elections elections
at the time were were not necessarily
the best idea because this is a country
that was devastated by multiple Wars
many of the people are either
or live in less education so it in a way
that the federal elections are the
elections has enhanced sectarianism more
than introduced it's because many of the
people who are Shias let's say voted for
Shia parties and certainly support for
Senate parties and Kurds birth of the
Kurds but and so as I as I now think
about it is that it's a democracy which
I think that's where I think the Iraq
war has failed miserably is that
democracy is not just about elections is
about institutions it's about civil
liberties is about all of these good
education good infrastructure that was
not I mean and that was not built even
though some may argue that was the
intention of the war but as you dig in
more and you see the corruption between
the contractors and other contractors
and suddenly just the money disappears
for some reason which was all meant for
kind of rebuilding institutions that is
I think what was really missing because
I think were we on the path until we
left right so you had elections I get
what you're saying
no could create a mess because
everyone's just gonna vote for their own
home parties like yeah but were we sort
of on the path and then just magically
left and then I mean the word roll was I
think even Democrats that I've talked to
and who are supportive thing as a
disaster is that I mean that one of the
things that they you I mean I was at the
time in Iraq as well is that the US was
doing with with with there's a movement
called awakening forces which are Sunni
militias fighting against al-qaeda it
was kind of acting as a neutral force
between all of these because the shares
don't see the Americans as Shias or
suddenly they see them as Americans so
or vice versa right so the tribes for
example were learning more the Sunni
tribes were more willing to work with
Americans that they were willing with
their work with the Iraqi with Iraq
Shias because they think they're lucky
shares are affiliated with Iran which is
their internal enemy so in a way America
was acting as a kind of a neutral force
that keeps all of these people together
and the moment that disappeared with
which is from the withdrawal which was
amazingly unplanned
the Iraq government which was sectarian
at the time and in a way still is
immediately pull out the funding from
all of the Sunnis that were fighting
against al-qaeda
so
many so so when that happened
immediately these guys who were fighting
against al-qaeda certainly they're
becoming a target to to still the
sleeping cell sleeper cells of the
terrorist group or they're like okay
what we're gonna fight for anymore so
then suddenly Isis comes up what a
surprise
so so so for those who actually followed
Iraq from all of the beginning to the
end
the Isis evolution makes absolute sense
right and there's probably a parable
here to in a way what's happening right
now with Turkey and the Kurds that we
were there yeah maybe we shouldn't have
been there you can make all those all
right no but we were there and now we
move these troops and now turkeys just
slaughtering these Kurds and it's like
alright so maybe if we did try to go for
good reasons you know holding that
debate aside yeah we were there we know
that the Kurds were basically our allies
there and now we've left just like we
sort of left there and yeah another
curse one one America is back to defend
them from all of the other factions that
are responsibility and all of it those
are I mean I do fortunes yeah I do think
it is I mean I think people on let's
call the liberal world for is that the
you we have to have to support a lot our
follow liberals or people at least
adhere to some I mean in Kurdish
factions there's communist and there are
other factions that there are there are
you say liberal just to clean up so you
mean G me just basic Western people
who's just a poor freedom and in general
and adhere to women's quality and all of
that so there's a funny quote that's
from from a Lebanese poet he said Sunnis
have Saudi Arabia Shias have Iran but
cigarettes have nobody but God so in a
way is that if we do not support those
who adhere to these values at least some
of them comparison to the others I'm not
sure that the YPG not adhere to Western
values or enlightenment values but they
are much better than the some of the
other factions I mean it's all by
comparison so if we're gonna let these
guys to be slaughtered then who do we
have left to support yeah I mean that is
one of the is that we need people on the
ground libertarian the purely
libertarian argument would be just get
the hell out
do it and that's that I always say is is
that the middle east is the opposite of
Las Vegas what happens in the Middle
East doesn't stay in the Middle East
yeah so you cannot leave this region
alone it's for me I mean I just came
back from Europe and I see a lot of the
refugees coming from Syria and another
war zones and this is an area that is
the central it's called the Middle East
it's in the middle of the world and it
is the birthplace of all the
monotheistic religions and its influence
on I mean it's also one of the richest
parts of the world because of oil and
natural gas and and we cannot be be left
alone and I mean the terrorists are the
extremists are not the ones leaving us
alone so the thing is that if you say
I'm gonna leave them alone it is on the
premise that there is kind of an
agreement and mutually assured
destruction here but there is not I mean
when you have a guy who wants to
establish a Caliphate and you're like no
it's more my business this is a bad deal
right but so do because the extremists
are expansionists next limits are not
gonna be happy I mean even Isis they
were not happy with just even though
they get AB large territory but they
were not happy with just this territory
they were willing to expand I mean they
have they don't get to a border and be
like all right we're going to go I mean
yeah they they are anti I mean them in
the Libertarians havoc of within which
like it's a word that is borderless is
that this they they see that their
ideology is borderless which is which is
true according to their interpretation
so so yeah so so I think is that leave
them alone policy and also it's like I
mean on what Travis I mean America has
intervened in the region so it's just
like you intervene and then you leave it
in a situation that is moderate you fix
it yeah yeah yes I do and how to
maintain all of that World Order with
all of a funeral intervene the Russians
well I was happened in Syria and if you
are gonna intervene the Turks well and
which world order you want to live in
just quickly on the Kurds I mean they
basically have the KRG basically has a
state in Iraq yes yeah I thought in my
autonomous you know if you just before
carving out that piece of Iraq
officially and just letting them have
that state I understand that you still
have the Syrian Kurds in the turkey
right
but do you think as an Iraqi do you
think that that basically would just be
fine I mean it sort of is I mean I think
it's all depends on what they want I
mean there are arguments and I and I'm
happily an ally of many Kurds and their
arguments on on some argue that we have
to stay as a part of Iraq and some of
them argue that they have to be
autonomous and there are because there's
a lot of natural resources that exist in
Iraq that kind of that they can rely on
and benefit from and also if you can
afford my stage you also might become
vulnerable at least now Iraq is a state
of some sort so that if there is a
Turkish invasion it'd still be a Turkish
invasion of Iraq in which where it's a
state versus a Kurdish state that they
will be vulnerable so there is that true
though with the with the Iraqi army
defend you think that if the KRG the
area got attacked you think the Iraqi
army would step in yes and maybe even
the US army right I mean the US Embassy
in Iraq is the largest embassy in the
world so so it's still there is a still
party yeah there's still infrastructure
that they can depend on so I mean I'm
I'm maybe this is men and extremists
agree on but I am for unity I mean I
mean I mean I agree that there needs to
be nation-states and there needs to be
in a way states are based on ethnic
groups because of the fact that they're
being persecuted but at the same time
it's I mean there are a lot of issues
that the that the world is now being
more interconnected than ever and we
have to so what happens in Iraq and what
happens in other states all connect to
each other so I'm a more in favor of
more unity than than division I mean we
got to create the division okay the
Kurds have their state how about the
Shia they have their state should they
be with Iran or should they be a
separate state or how about the
sentences they be with Saudi Arabia like
there's always gonna be think we're
divided in America that must be hilarya
yes so who's gonna who's gonna be
represented about marginal tax rates and
you're like come on this is not scary
but real quick I think we have to
bizarrely give Hillary Clinton a
shout-out here because I don't you when
did you move to America 2009 2009 2013
yeah so during the campaign the first
Obama campaign yeah when they were in
the primary hill
verse Obama I don't know if you saw this
from the outside but Hillary kept saying
we have to leave Iraq but we have to do
it responsibly
with the timeline and this whole thing
Oh bomb except saying no we've got to go
we've got to go and that was in the
midst of the hope and change thing and
just everybody like just drinking the
the kool-aid yeah and then he did do it
and then as you're saying it led to a
lot of those things so in a weird way
Hillary actually deserves some credit
for for being honest at least about what
what should have been done as opposed to
just the rash decision yeah to just get
going I mean at the end of the day we're
going to talk about my organization a
bit is there I think that at the end of
the day people in the Middle East have
the fix our region I mean I'm not in
favor of interventionism forever or even
interventionism in some cases is that at
the end of the day the people of the
region have to choose their own destiny
and that destiny should not be
antagonistic to the world and so which
brings up the need that we cannot rely I
mean I mean I think I think now is more
than ever and even previously the United
States is not a reliable partner if you
are fighting in the region the United
States might switch left to right and
and some people might use the
interventionism as an argument for
getting votes and some people might get
do not gain votes at the end of the day
you cannot rely on that and it is in a
way a weakness of the United States
because as a democracy you can have all
the shifts well for example with Russia
I was having a call with a was actually
a Syrian nut militia but he's a kind of
an an observer and it was like at least
with the Russians I know what's gonna
happen in the next 10 years with the
Chinese I know we're gonna have the next
15 years but with the Americans okay we
can have the interventions president
like Bush for example and then you can
have a bomb after that and now I don't
know what the show is but it's an
interesting sort of soft spot of
democracy
I mean these the problems in many of
these issues extremism authoritarian
these are need long term solutions I
mean even for example which is kind of
we rely that as a basic of what people
ask us about theory of change is that in
the Cold War when the United States
pushed for that communism was evil and
we had this values and we have to spread
them or defend them that was
consistent policy in both Democrats and
Republicans like you see here JFK
talking about communism in the same way
that Reagan was talking about communism
is that there was not this split about
who is the enemy and how can we fix it
was consistent policy that we stand for
these values as a state and this value
which is communism which is spreading a
spreading around the world we have to
put a stop into it and this is a
long-term solution so if the Democrats
want is the Republicans want it doesn't
matter if America and I think that if
there is gonna be constant intervention
or state solution to this which I'd
necessarily not solely believe in it but
because I'm more on the non state
intervention because I think that the
states have 10 I mean New York subway
barely work so so forget about fixing
the Middle East but so I think it's that
you just became a citizen if you're
already railing ironically the best
subway system probably in the world know
as terrible as it is it runs 24 hours
it's great but I think is that this this
issues back to Liz that these issues
need long-term solutions and this
polarization of America would left a
right and all that is really harming our
partners I think at the end of the day
which I'm setting up with Morgan ization
and and and other allies and partners we
have to empower the people there in the
region to be self-sufficient yeah at the
end of the day the goal is
self-sufficiency for the people who hold
of our values and and and for them to
fight for it out of themselves and fight
for others well that's why I brought up
the Hillary thing because it's
interesting we just have to think about
these things seriously - whatever stent
we're gonna think about them because
just saying okay something Bad's
happening we're just getting the hell
out of there and just because we it
makes us feel good yeah it didn't
necessarily the wise thing it doesn't
mean that staying is the right thing but
at least be willing to think about some
of these things I think that he's talked
about them honestly one of the mazing
quotes which I which I always remember
from David Petraeus who was at the hand
at the time the head of the multi
coalition forces in Iraq he said the
only time were actually able to defeat
terrorism in Iraq which actually he
didn't support in which one we cared
about the citizens of Iraq as much as we
cared about the citizens of the United
States
so any policy that is I mean in a way is
that being compassionate is actually a
winning policy against success because
if you I mean as in case of give talks
and stuff if the conversation is always
about okay how is that gonna benefit the
United States not to say that this
should not be a policy if you work at
the State Department but I think is that
the best policy is a policy that looks
at that target audience or the people
there and like okay we care about your
safety as well not okay you guys kill
each other and we're gonna sit on basis
and at least protect ourselves I think
there should be and it has been applied
before which actually I mean with the
with the Petraeus situation he worked
with a lot of Sunni allies it's called
the awakening forces at the time and
which they actually were able to defeat
al-qaeda step by step they were they
formed this when they saw that
okay well the Americans actually care
about us that they are not just
opportunist who who would throw us under
the bus right but rather care about our
lives as much as they care about their
Army's lives and when that happened
actually there was a defeat for al Qaeda
that's basically like when the surge was
happy yes yes yes that was yesterday
search was complementary to these two
these Sunni allies who were fighting so
I think that is the best policy it's not
okay
the this costs too much for us or this
it should not be looked at it in this
way it should be that if we're gonna
defeat terrorism we have to side with
allies there and give them our words and
actually stick with it not flip around
so I want to switch sort of to you
coming to America and everything you've
done since then yes I thought an
interesting transition told this would
be you probably saw it just in the last
couple weeks Ellen DeGeneres had to go
on her show and basically sort of
apologize for sitting in a box at a
football game with George W Bush and
because everybody was saying george w
bush is a mass murderer and got us into
Iraq and all things and I thought that's
kind of consistent with a lot of the
pushback that say I get on some of the
things or the but but really let's make
this about you you are the guest when
you come to America talk about
some of these issues I know for you it's
been really bizarre to find out who the
people that kind of hate you are and
where your allies come from can you talk
about that a little bit its I mean on
that nose you're another kind of
apostate you're not just a religious
upon is actually after so how to walk
experience or Chinese think sharing I've
decided
almost like fifty two months ago fifty
days ago that I'm not gonna read the
news I'm actually I'm only gonna focus
on my work and how and if there's any
news that is relevant to my work I won't
get it for my stuff so I I said I've
done I've had a policy which I which is
sometimes inconsistent because I've been
following the clot of habit with the
Kurds and everything but I was like if
that is something I am
number one not my expertise number two
incapable of changing why am i bothering
myself because all along get is getting
complete agitation give me you don't
want to tweet okay so putting aside
yelling you know what I'm talking about
with the general philosophy to America
yeah you're you're a brown-skinned
immigrants yeah come here you you really
start getting successive friends and all
of these things and you're talking about
these issues when was the first moment
that you realized whoa the people that
are supposed to be supporting me here in
America are not and the ones that I
thought we're gonna hate me
suddenly support me if that's a fair way
of starting it it's it's so interesting
I mean that that has been an ongoing
discussion internally not to sound like
like a crazy person but what you've had
an externally we've been talking about
you you were actually one of the first
people the first time you were on my
show yeah was one of the first times
that I really fully understood it from
another perspective yeah I was seeing it
from my own perspective o of the Left
East kind of abandoning yeah but but
seeing I mean truly just because of your
identity in a way and where you come
yeah I was like oh this one's just
really obvious now I know everyone sees
this I mean them the best example I
think ethics an article you tweeted
about what happened in University of
Rochester and I was talking about that
the need for Friday
be amorous and everything and then there
was I think someone she had like a
Marxist thing on her back and they were
amazingly disruptive and then she I mean
she was shouting at me and she was
insulting and all of that and she was
accusing me of there's other one in in
Portland State University in which I was
accused of spreading white supremacy
what they called me a homophobic
christina hoff sommers a anti-feminist
yeah so so that is it is actually one of
the most the strangest things I mean and
I'm absent in Europe as well is this
unholy alliance that between the far
left and and and the Islamists in a way
the the it's funny in Iraqi elections
the last Iraqi elections the Communists
and the Islamists were in the same
coalition party which is really
interesting because I think is that
there is a correlation of the ideology
between those who are far leftist and
Islam is that they really hate the same
people which is in a way the
capitalistic or neoliberalism whatever
they want to call it but it's the middle
is the real cohesion they're just
because they both want state power right
like they want it for different reasons
but it's almost like like here the way I
would view it is the the reason that the
Islamists love the progressives is
because the progressives are trying to
attain state power and then the
progressives will just sort of be the
last ones to be bedded I mean I mean
that kind of metaphorically that's like
a fair estimation because it's both
about accumulating power I think for
different reasons I think you're putting
too much thinking into it I think is
that the people like that at least the
ones that I have talked to who are would
sympathize with long really don't have
any idea with it what they talk
about they know they know what they hate
and mostly talk about the is that they
know what they hate yeah and they know
as they go with this more ideologies
coming of intersectionality or all of
that so they know what the enemy is so
in a way they agree with that I don't
know what they're do they would so okay
this fits the identity politics that we
want to fulfill and and I've talked
about this I think on your show but the
zoo theory
in which they want to rainbow and oh
here is a panda and here is a so they
want this diversity so they put the hey
job Ian yeah because she looks authentic
so in a way they are committing racism
itself by putting an act within a
religion or in their ways connected
religion ethnicity and to like a certain
look so so yeah so that is it is an
onion progress it's just absurd it's
just absurd hopefully yeah I would put
you I'm in six years and a half in I
mean I just don't know how to make any
sense of it just we got we gotta keep
going with this though because though
when they see you rules
yeah they should be all about you they
should and some of them have I mean
that's that I think that for me to have
at least from an organizational
perspective you should donate I think is
that people but but the thing is that I
look at I mean I I need allies but at
the same time many supporters which i
think is a bit different and I've
mysteriously which is something that I
would like to try to but one day and I
think is that that university world and
I'm actually I'm cutting a lot of my
speaking engagements in universities for
that reason and also the social media is
really I mean I think your bio says to
Twitter is not real world right yeah
is that Twitter is not really many many
Americans are really nice people
yeah like I mean I can say that with
with with certainty now as I've been now
to 40 states and I've lived actually I
was hosted by a family who is gulliver's
who are she's Mexican Chinese married to
a Native American African American and
they loved they loved me and they were
like semi conservative and semi liberal
and hosted me in their house for a year
and I so custom my American family and I
got to know these are not the people you
see on college campuses or you see on
Twitter right now these are they can be
progressive on some others that
and conservative and others and there
have been this type of mix school not
the ideologues of what side this kind of
mix have been our biggest allies for the
organism and for me it's an individual
but also has their organization so I
think is that that I think there's also
study done on Twitter is that how that
those who actually on Twitter are those
crazy maniacs it's kind of a
self-selection is that this is we like
even even I had a lot of prejudices
against the right when I moved to the
United States yeah that's exactly and
for and when I and obviously hearing the
the the left-wing or or that that
section that talk shows and they have
made a bogeyman of these people and
other than the the actual boogeyman and
those who are also talk-show hosts of
the right-wing establishment but most
people who are conservative or also very
nice people you know so I think is that
that is the problem is that how can we
give these guys platform which I think
you are you're doing some of us some of
thing is that wait who do you mean these
guys those who are actually saying
people who are not fighting with I'm
trial they're not like starting at Dave
Rubin or like I try so look you know
that these are unfortunately they are
very loudest in most of the but if you
mean I'm now realizing it after I said
that quit the news and even social media
I only post selfies of meeting shawarma
yeah
but I think is that as I go outside and
I now yeah many people are really nice
it's because you know I traveled the
country the world actually about 20
countries over the last year on tour
with Jordan and that also my main
takeaway was that yeah that especially
it is particularly unique here in the
United States yeah great everyone is
like okay so now as a citizen here
that's been here for six plus years yeah
probably
how often do you face hate and face
racism let's say from the quarters that
they would tell you you're supposed to
be getting it from our the Trump
supporters hunting you down I mean thank
goodness not know that I know but no I
mean I mean I think
but I mean we go out all the time yeah
and you make all sorts of funny Arabic
jobs owners and waitresses you're by the
way the only person I know that when you
sit down at a restaurant you order two
drinks that way I get the red wine you
get a beer and demarkus I know I'm gonna
order them so might as well get them
together
margarita just starts melting I know
trying to explain my physics knowledge
is very limited but yeah III I mean but
really do you face any great any racism
in America any anti immigrant so Sonny
so yes and yes and no mind the truck I
mean you thank you invited me to be on
your show when the travel ban happened
and my mom was in Iraq when that so that
thing affected actually me personally
overall I mean yes I I think it being
any public figure of any sort
you get hate this part of the game but
it's much significantly less I mean I
mean there's no way comparison like like
I mean maybe my standards are low I mean
I don't mean hate like oh I don't like
his policy I'm something like that I
mean that you are a brown immigrant in
the United States yeah no I mean I
overall I would say yeah I mean by any
comparison like compared to living in
the Middle East to here there's no way I
mean not even I mean I mean I think
things that they're they're obviously
some people have different definitions
but I think is it diabla thing to my
life no I'm having I think my most
account is a good life I love living in
America I love my friends here III think
that I now have a strong bond to this
country as a country accepted me from
the environment tries to live in and
really gave me that I think the American
Dream I mean I think I'm a symbol of it
in a way well that's why I love being
your pose I love Instagram and you you
know when you just posted all the stuff
from the party that you had when you
when you proficient got the big American
hat on the American and it's like you
are the American dream to me I really
believe that and the people who attended
that party by the way I had a party to
be a US citizen and the people came for
party are from every version of whether
humanity or political views
and no I think I think is that those who
can always look for fights will find
them as in any case but I think is that
and obviously everyone's experience is
different I mean I don't live in I don't
know small town or I don't live in the
Bronx you know there's there I think
these people might have different
experiences that I do but I think I mean
I would be dishonest to play this
identity politics so I'm a victim here
and I think I've done events with you in
Texas yeah then we'd gone to local bars
yeah
redneck bars I remember that's how we
were in but we went to that what the
average person would think is some
middle America redneck bar yeah not a
great freakin time and nobody cared and
outright you're always loud and laughing
nobody cares no no yeah I think I think
this these are a lot of polarizing
misconceptions that need to be fought I
mean I I mean my parents live in Texas
by the way all my exes live in I say
they done they live in California but
but I know I mean my parents live in
Texas I go to many of you ever got Texas
quite a lot yeah I mean this the this
misconception that people there are a
bunch of racist and I mean I've also
been to like small town there's the area
called Fredericksburg Texas which is has
kind of German wineries and beers and
stuff and many people that were like
Texans and they were not antagonistic
whatsoever they were very friendly
yeah can you talk a little bit about
because you've been traveling a lot
yeah oh you were in Europe just yeah
last couple days actually how the sort
of integration thing or race
conversation or the rest of how that's
different here than it is in Europe
you're finding I mean my if there's one
or two describe it it's dense man it's
dense I mean what you were in Denmark
you yes UK I was in Denmark mostly yeah
I was in Denmark for like seven eight
days and then I went to Norway and I
went to the okay that the thing is like
and also I've been to Germany and the UK
in some music my American possibilities
oh yeah actually I just
when I get the passport I was like let
me go to kind of that today be tested
does this really work and I went to
Montreal I was like oh this
actually works and I was like okay I can
go to Europe now of ancillaries you just
wanted to test it the closest country I
love you get you become an American
citizen you get a sharp leather jacket
and you immediately go to Europe I think
is that I mean obviously I think the
main difference between the United
States and in Europe is that everybody
can be American America is a land of
immigrants at the core of it is that the
identity is attached to values I mean
when I became a US citizen it was I mean
the test is easy but it's like okay what
what does the United States without the
Bill of Rights freedom of speech all of
that you mean you didn't have to pledge
allegiance to white power no not this
time no but but they said come back in
five years but I think is that so that's
mixture of like that this is a state
based upon values I mean that's one of
the reasons I mean I was actually hired
possibilities I mean I was rejected for
hunting that Kingdom but I had
possibilities of entering different
States and Europe to emigrate even
though I was in that tough situation
which I would take it
regardless would come I if I had the
choice I would choose America and I
would still choose it again is that this
is a land that is based on values and so
as a result see you and I have in
conversation we've had a margarita
together multiple states and I think yes
while this can happen in different
European states which is that Europe has
a Europe in a way like Asia is part of
the old world and there is history and
there are conflicts there that if you
are an immigrant it is used I mean when
I was in Denmark it was obvious I was a
foreigner mmm it was obvious I was a
foreigner because Denmark has a king and
has a history and has in a way specific
tribe that eventually became a state as
in the case of of many
although they are struggling a little
bit less with the immigration issue than
the other Scandinavian countries right
at least that was my take I mean it
depends who you ask some people I mean
now I think the mail for Social
Democrats are getting tough on
immigration to protect the welfare state
and solve that so so as a result it's
like so you have this kind of I would
say the threshold to integrate is more
difficult than America I think I think
America is easy to integrate to I think
many people there is a it's a melting
pot it's I mean some guys like oh you're
not American enough well like I was like
I drink but like yeah but but no it's
like someone really ever said yeah yeah
and actually that would get to my
question the guy was the guy from
England you're not an American I was
like like I don't have time for you but
I think is that the threshold to enter
American society or to integrate them
around is different I think so there
it's more difficult to integrate by
default is more difficult into it
imagine you are from Aleppo and you grew
up in a religious Muslim background in
which you were taught that the West is
is an enemy or your values are more
superior to their values clash
immediately happens is that like it's
it's already I mean the poles are
difficult to integrate in Denmark leave
aside somebody from Raqqa or our small
town Syria like so and so as a result it
is so you have this state with to some
extent strong identity that is tied to
the history and tied to to to win some
extent ethnic identity which is not I'm
a fan of but these are it's a different
history and then it is not easy to even
if you are like let's say even if you
are the secular open-minded you might
also be viewed differently and imagine
if you are not secular open-minded so
now we are going minus 50 on on level of
integration and and if you want to
not only that you want to abuse their
system or then the class expands so so
in a way is that some of the bad
immigrants who moved there have just
like in any case of extremism is that
they also ignited the far-right so now
that for right and so now there's like
this huge tension between the far-right
in Europe and then the Islamists who are
getting more and more organized and
unfortunately the victims of that are
the good immigrants you really have
nothing to do with all of that
edge of course is most yeah and I mean
I've talked to some of them who really
love love living in Europe and and and
and I mean it's it's a privilege I mean
in to live in a society that that gives
you rights and and and and come as it's
a privilege I mean not everybody mass
people in the world still live in
authoritarian states I mean it's a
privilege to live in liberal democracies
and are you shocked that so many people
in the West or let's just take it from
an American yeah give now that you're in
America are you so are you shocked at so
many Americans you're just afraid to say
what you're saying right now like even
before you just you repeatedly said
values no I know pretty much that all 12
of those Democratic candidates be scared
to say something like I believe in
American values because the implication
is somehow that means something racist
now right so the only people you have
talking about values are conservatives
or say this that fringe far-right people
that's what it's not gonna mean it yeah
we're talking about is that they talk
about values but they talk about values
all it directed to their way
conservative Christians or kind of or
far-right and even though these have
several categories but but yeah it's and
that's what cultural relativism talk
about yeah that's what cultural
relativism is is very cancerous because
it's that that I mean which is again
back to the accusations that I get is
that I'm trying to westernize
that the Arabs or something like that
and it was like when John Stuart Mill
wrote because we translated a lot of
milk so we're gonna get to that is that
Joe sort Mel when he said freedom of
speech in this a phenom speech for white
people or people in
in England he said freedom of speech is
a universal human right that should be
applied everywhere and the fact that
that people from there protesting in the
streets now in Baghdad in Syria are
demanding these rights what to deny them
these rights in the name cultural
relativism is racist and harmful so it's
a mix of both it's dangerous and racist
so so saying that in and what I find it
all so interesting is that cultural
relativism no I want to go to
philosophical is itself self-destructive
because if you if cultural tourism is
law everything is relative then this is
an objective statement so back sure by
the fact that you are saying everything
is relative
you are making an objective statement in
a way it's a so as also everyone knows
it's not true not everything is equal
not every some countries throw gays or
prove some don't that's not not not in
values of course and the thing is like
we we know now we know better I mean
that's one of the things that that I
mean you have interviewed Steven Pinker
on your show and stated Pinker have
written this amazing book I mean I call
him the Ayatollah Pheidias beyond
borders and Steven Pinker out this book
enlightenment now which is which is
there it is right there that's and we
we've happily translated and the thing
is it talks about that these are the
values that a lot of the manners of how
they made the world better everywhere
they were applied so it really identity
politics and and it's relevant here is
that what you have societies that how
better women's rights have better
quality how better freedom they become
better that is an objective and and he
has a full freakin book with data yeah
so what is the argument so that's the
thing with with is that they don't have
an argument against that they don't have
an argument that if you allow women
rights and LGBT and minority rights
individual rights to flourish in this
country these guys become they'll have
an argument against that so what they do
is that they shape the argument into all
you are your white supremacist or
westernizing and I was like no the
people from there wanted you think that
people from their dome
to write this value it would only make
sense if you didn't think that Western
values and enlightenment values were
good but they are universally good
exactly it said and and and there are
Arab estates for example Tunisia when
they have applied women's art they
became better States so so it's that's
why I was saying that it's both racist
and dangerous because you're denying
people there who you know that the
values are good and you know that they
work but you deny them because you in
the name of whatever the ideology you
want to justify so I think it's that
that's why I think I mean those who
there there are two sides that actually
get access and both of them are racist
in my opinion the first one is the
culture optimist which is oh these are
our values who are we to tell them and
then the other one will be like oh these
values are only attached to the white
race and these other brown people can
end it here to them yeah so is that um
so that voice there so I get I think we
and everyone watching this understands
the first version yeah I think cuz it's
what we do all the time that other
version though who is that I mean I mean
it's not just like an online boys
because I don't see that necessarily
I've had I've had some conversations
with a lot of I mean political parties
in Europe who in a way play on this so
so that's interesting to me yeah I think
it's a more of a European yes I mean I
need to spend more time talking with
American politicians but I think I think
in America is probably much less is that
I mean that's why I'm very worried not
using the term Western values because
when somebody attaches a value system
into a region it becomes okay it gets
complicated
right so when some people say Western
values they all some of these faction of
these people mean that only Westerners
adhere to these values or all the
Westerners can hear to these values so
it's sometimes very important to
actually differentiate I mean I don't
think people say Western Ballard's are
racists but I think is that there's two
factions within those who will which is
in a way the
same as the cultural device is actually
no different whatsoever right is that it
is cultural relativism so it's not
nothing I mean I mean on a personal also
organizational level I mean we have not
been attacked by any prominent figure
within people who had fought advocated
that and our organization so that's
that's good but I think I mean I've had
some conversations with with some
parties some more swedish and somewhere
and who are like and and they kept
saying that in a way again similar to
cultural relativism is that you are
acting Western and you're acting white
because you want people to be free yes
so so so in a way there is I mean kind
of the horseshoe theory in ways like
they are really similar yeah in a way
well I'm glad you clarified the
elephants between from an American and
European yeah because from an American
perspective yes there are little fringe
voices on the internet that I see so
yeah yeah but no real institutional
power or anything yeah no not not that I
know of yeah I mean if I if I find
someone I will tweet at them please all
right wait we have to finish up by
talking specifically about ideas yes
borders you mentioned John Stuart Mill
you know I've got a copy of on Liberty
on my nightstand later
can you write something in Arabic on it
that would actually be pretty great I
can do it I'm gonna put gutters great no
talk to me about exactly what ideas
Beyond Borders is doing because you guys
have translated hun yes three thousand
and one hundred articles as of now and
twelve books amazing just where did this
idea really come from and what are you
guys doing
so the first actually is very relevant
of conversations that the first at that
we depend a lot of organization about is
that from the United Nations Development
Report for the Arab world it says that
there are more books translated to
Spanish in one year than Arabic in one
thousand years and also only 0.6 percent
of Internet content is in Arabic even
though it's a language spoken by four
hundred plus million people as I was
growing up in in Iraq thank goodness I
was bilingual I was I was
English is a very young age and as a
result I was able to access the
alternative voice in that case the
liberal voice if you are if you're an
Arab young man growing up in Iraq and
you rock but all over and if you search
about basic stuff about human rights
freedom of religion all of that the two
main things you get are either from
authoritarian state or extremists even
though many people are hooked to the
Internet but really the information that
they are getting yeah just hit a wall
it's really from I mean in the bad guys
right that those who want to advance so
I as somebody who up there
and and I now having the privilege of
being safe number one and being able to
connect to people like you and be on
media and connect is that IBB is
becoming a platform to help people in
the region who adhere to all values to
translate and distribute the materials
that make the world a better place which
are a lot even values so we started with
a small office and then I started
pitching the idea around to young Arabs
not to Westerners but the younger is
that something we want yes is the answer
is yes and then we formed the team I
mean now we're expanding to 120
translators all across the region
demanding and translating this content
about enlightenment to be translated and
viewed by our abuse and so that it took
the connect to all of that is that
living in the Iraq war and seeing all of
these things is that this war on terror
or bombing of terrorists all I deal with
the tip of the iceberg
we kill the Paladins and recall the
Isis's but that doesn't deal with the
root of the problem which is values
extremist values are bring destruction
and enlightenment values bring hope and
and prosperity it's clear it's factual
and these values need to be those who
adhere to them need to be supported and
these values need to be spread to
counter extremist narrative and even
replace it in the future so that is kind
of the gist of ideas being borrowed is a
provide
it is to prevent extreme at the mention
of organization is preventing extremism
before it takes root so in that way if
you change the ecosystem of information
which they get the Steven Pinker's and
the John Stuart Mill's and they read
them and then when an extremist guy
comes in to them and it's like how do
you want to establish a Caliphate and
all of that the answer will be no and
not only to be recruited territorialism
but to reject all of that ideology which
is the Islamist ideology which is of
having at alternate state built on on
religion or other authoritarians like
like the rest so we've actually hired a
tremendous which actually brings us back
the concept of cultural relativism
instead our content has been a few
twelve million times in Arabic this is
not I'm not targeting students of
Rochester I'm targeting young Arabs and
oh and we have 4.5 million followers so
at the beginning I was like I was like
maybe what people will not read this
content is - the demand is there people
want this at least I think some of it is
relative to two-timed is that they have
seen what Islamist look like they live
under them for them for me al-qaeda is
not just something I see on television I
lived and relocated I've seen if you
lived under al-qaeda why not try an
extremist like so that so they don't the
thing is like many of the young people
don't need convincing
honestly that these the values of the
extremists suck but they need an
alternative and we are trying to provide
that context and knowledge in which
these people be able to access it and
now we are in the third phase in which
we actually want to build a movement on
the ground which is back to the
self-sufficiency argument is that I want
this movement that believes
enlightenment values to be everywhere to
run for marrow elections to be on
television to have a video blog so the
so that is the other angle which is
empowerment angle we make the knowledge
available but also we empower those who
had here today these ideas and let them
lead the way
and we run surveys which I love to share
one day with is the we run service about
ok what do you guys need to be transient
enlightenment
that's what some of these people want to
transit they want to know books about
freedom of speech we don't fall in all
of these stuff that we value as when my
book comes out in April don't purr in
this book and we can we translate it
sure
just talk to your agent because
sometimes a pain in the ass I said I
want to mention that because I think it
is it's we've had some difficulty you're
in the book by the way oh yeah as well
as a shawarma is that we've had so with
another name and shame but we've had
some issues so for example the author
will be like oh please translate my book
I don't want money it's it's for the
youth and all of that I'll do it for
free obviously thank you yeah then the
agents are will be like no I want
$10,000 and then we're like we're a
small nonprofit what we're but I'm good
at $10,000
so sometimes is that even because I
think some translation rights are not
owned by the author they're owned by the
publishing house and as a result we've
had many authors who were trying to
offer us their book and then the
conversation just ended with the agent
were like oh if you don't give us 10,000
so so we're getting a little insider
baseball no no but my agents won't do it
I'll pay whatever it is okay okay thank
you we could do this all day long I know
do this over dinner in a couple days in
New York but you really like doing this
show it's like I've met so many people I
love and admire and that we're heroes of
mine and great authors and theta but
we've really become real friends out on
this room and and you are exactly what
the American Dream is all about and I'm
just so thrilled that later maybe only
when I'm on the plane tonight I'm gonna
go back and look at that first interview
that we did and that the fact that you
built this thing and you're successful
and you're now a citizen man I think
this is the same stuff I would say ad
well kind of it but really I love it I'm
thrilled for you and for you guys check
out ideas Beyond Borders org if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our international playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists there all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell